we got the story just real quick hold
that thought in yeah T-Mobile phones
will connect to starlink for free
starting next year and this is from
August you see all we had to do was
Google it we're behind the times on this
one they're going to set up what's going
to happen is you're gonna be able to
call Mars when people start
um habitating Mars and it'll take two
hours to get your voice message over
there and then they're going to realize
sympathetic vibration and they're going
to put crystals in the satellites and
Chris and it'll create like an
entanglement system not quite
entanglement but where the creates
sympathetic vibration between nodes and
you'll have instantaneous communication
is is this is Elon does he have a bigger
master plan behind all of this how much
did he pay for buying x.com he's had it
since the 90s exactly well I think he
had to buy a website to buy it back
right yeah yeah and he spent like a
record amount of money on that I saw
Elon XCOM I wonder if he played XCOM
yeah I saw him he tweeted cancel culture
must be canceled or something like that
right and I'm like he does say a whole
lot of things that come off as like
overly generic you know he's he's
pandering to the Free Speech crowd
look man he's getting a lot of people to
cheer for what he's building so keep an
eye out man I'm concerned he's in an
echo chamber I've been thinking that
lately like people will tweet at
whatever he's going through they'll
tweet it at him and he'll respond to
that what if I get it that's what he's
going through what if it's a psyop
within a psyop a false flag within a
false flag setting up the media to
attack him so he looks favorable because
you know after after the the the last
two presidential elections we learned
when you know the corporate media
attacks you especially with the rise of
Donald Trump they kind of prop you up so
what if this is all kind of planned and
engineered this is where my
conspiratorial mind is going to right
now that we'll end up with our brain
chips on the X app essentially having a
life that's controlled with satellites
watching our every single move as we are
living under you know the the Tesla
production facility of uh robotic pods
and uh bugs providers to eat the
governors Elon Musk is also uh you know
you know he's also a big on global
warming he's also big on world
government as well so those are things
that I would just be extremely skeptical
of and this is why again what Elon Musk
is doing is commendable but there's a
small part of me that's skeptical it's
the risk we take as humans with our
current structure we'll give one guy so
much power to create a an Empire and
then hope that he doesn't turn on us as
humans and over time you see people turn
on people like they get bought out they
get bribed or they die and someone else
takes over the Empire so we're in a
risky place with Elon with so much power
hopefully it will evolve into a system
instead of uh a guy's toy I think the
only writ the the good thing about
having the richest guy in the world do
this though is that he can't really be
bought because at this point like money
is kind of meaningless and he even said
that he he doesn't want to buy Twitter
to make money because well number one
like honestly once you get to whatever
billion he's at like what is another
billion what is another three billion
he's taking initial losses on this but
he wants to turn the company profitable
um and actually like the terms for x.com
were not disclosed but he bought it back
from pay PayPal in 2017 but yeah so so
what's another like couple billion to
him so that that's the only reason that
I think he's doing it in good faith is
like what does he need more money for
honestly I also want to point out this
TechCrunch article they say at first the
service will only enable text messages
and possibly messaging apps yeah and
Twitter yeah exactly Twitter so people
will be able to engage in the
conversation from the middle of the
Mojave Desert or or who knows where else
Burning Man from burning they'll be
tweeting all the birding Man photos well
you can't do the photos just you know
but highlighting you'll be able to send
it here can't believe I found them at
this Dome with the crystals you can't
believe where he put him I wonder if the
the Free Speech stuff from Elon is just
to Rally people to support him he was
talking about how a bunch of Democrats
all came out at one started attacking
him and I'm willing to bet that he
immediately was like okay I need some
allies so you know I'm gonna I want to
do my thing I want to build this stuff
okay Free Speech we want Twitter anyway
let's start unbanning people and make
this Talk of the Town
I I I don't know though you know maybe
maybe it's out of the kindness of his
heart the The Good the the the uh the
strong morals he has that he wants to
stand by free speech
and then you read these stories from
back in August you think about the stuff
that he's intended to build people have
already mentioned months ago I think a
year ago that Twitter would be great for
uh interplanetary communication because
you put out a message and it's available
to be seen by anyone anywhere as opposed
to I'm gonna message you and then it's
gonna come to just you yes you could put
a message it goes to The Ether everyone
can see it when they're available to see
it
I think that's or he's just just having
a good time and there's also I mean
there's also a lot of data and a lot of
information that you could get on the
the general public through Twitter you
could see I I mean there's a reason
intelligence agencies launch campaigns
for civil unrest in foreign countries on
social media and use it as their main
kind of uh rallying call and organize
and call there's a reason
um Apple just got rid of Bluetooth
connection and the ability to airdrop
messages in China a few days ago because
they understand with the Chinese
government controlling
um the cell phone connectivity there
with with them controlling the internet
there the one thing that they don't
control is Bluetooth to Bluetooth
peer-to-peer communication Apple got rid
of that they blocked airdrop yeah
airdrop on beheads of the Chinese
government because this was the main
tool that the Chinese government that
that the Chinese protesters that were
calling for more freedom were using in
order to communicate with each other
without being punished so now the you
know the Chinese police we're literally
going around from person to person
checking their cell phones in the subway
as they were walking walking down the
street in order to stop them from
sharing any kind of information let me
let me show you guys this ridiculous uh
video right here nice uh look at this
strapping young lad from 10 years ago is
that Elliott page right there is that
sweat out that's uh that's me standing
for some reason in a forest wearing a
very tight shirt I guess looking good
and uh I was doing a report on this new
patent that came out it this this is 10
years ago YouTube put it was on the
front page it was on like World Star
Hip-Hop YouTube's old now basically and
I made this like little animation
breaking down how it works and uh they
were they were patenting this technology
that they could go into their Maps
isolate a certain area on the map
geofencing and then if you entered that
portion your phone would be disabled and
they were like oh think about it you
enter a movie theater your camera
doesn't work and everyone's like yeah or
you're at a protest and you can't film
the cops anymore
or you're in China and you're
communicating via Bluetooth and they
turn it off that's crazy to hear that
they're doing it and there was there
were like a lot of people said Tim they
never did this you're wrong it's like
okay man you know it's it's probably not
the same exact thing
but it's creepy that it's it's so
similar I'm not a big fan of apple as a
company I never have been in in the 90s
I thought they were proprietary couldn't
game on their systems you had to get
your own unique power supply all these
unique pieces and parts and then it was
way overpriced uh Steve Jobs brilliant
you know brilliant I don't know profit
you could call him I guess he has great
and they have great design but I do not
like the way that they organize their
company I don't like that they're
they're siding with the Chinese
government over the freedom people that
are trying to protest being free of
being locked in their homes but Apple's
gonna side with the people locking them
in their homes meanwhile they made a
huge statement about George Floyd and
all the freedoms that they're fighting
for here in the United States meanwhile
what are they doing in China with the
protests essentially starting at the
foxcom factory facility where you know
the Chinese people were forced to make
iPhones forced to make Apple products so
I believe some people this is the what
really kicked off these Chinese protests
which we probably should talk even more
about is that people were locked in
their homes for covid and and the
building caught fire and like 20 people
burned to death yeah that's one story
out of many horrific horror stories of
insanity happening in that country
there's videos of them welding doors
again again yeah there's videos of like
them torturing and beating someone up at
their own home with their children
watching because they criticized the
coveted lockdown policies online there's
so much Insanity there's so many cruel
just absolutely insane videos they were
walking around with sticks beating up
and killing dogs because they thought
that they were spreading diseases this
is the this is the policy that that
Klaus Schwab said is the example for the
world to follow this is the policy that
Bill Gates said this is what we need to
implement here this is what Dr fauci
knew was happening saw the report saw
the investigations and said we need to
implement this here in the United States
and they almost did and they were very
we were very lucky that we have
something called the first and second
amendment and I think that's the only
thing that stood in the way of total
tyranny taking over all of the United
States which I think we were very close
to achieve it you're talking about the
zero covet policy yes look at Europe I
mean they locked down they were much
more harsh Australia Australia
absolutely New Zealand I mean you know
what you know what man I you know who I
feel bad for is uh Claire Lehman you
guys know Claire right yeah yeah poor
lady Colette was this you know
intellectual dark web free speech and
then Australia announces they're you
know gonna set up camps where they can
take people against their will to detain
them because of covid call it whatever
you want and people were trying to
escape these places because people
couldn't leave their cubicles and uh
Claire Lehman of quillette this was like
you know Free Speech intellectual
thought all of a sudden it's just like
this is okay lockdowns are good and I
imagine the reason is she's in the
system she is within the walls of the
machine that is doing this to people and
uh if she speaks up she gets thrown in
huh yeah or she gets taken down or they
come after her and she showed that she
was terrified of the machine around
founder either that or she completely
betrayed all of the principles she
espoused before but either way she's
fake and they were literally copying and
pasting the same policies that they were
testing and implementing in China in
China they're still building 90 000
quarantined facilities uh for sorry 90
000 individual boots pods four people to
to live in in major cities all
throughout China so so again these These
are camps that people are thrown in many
times not even for testing uh positive
many times for being around someone that
was maybe sick and other times for
criticizing the government people just
get thrown in these pods as we saw in
Australia people were thrown in there
without any tests without any close
contacts they were just arguing that
police officers the police officers had
had enough saying no two-week quarantine
you're done absolutely insane policies
that's what happens when you give people
power too it's like if they can do that
for covid or for medical reasons why
can't they do that for disagreement
right and who's who's to say like for
evidence like there there is no evidence
there's you know no one to prove that
they do or do not have covet for
um so yeah and in America I think it
didn't get to that point but like
obviously like vaccine cards and then we
didn't have like the vaccine mandate for
for planes necessarily but like fauci
went on TV saying yeah we're not ruling
anything out like we tried yeah they did
yeah and then I think they saw the
American people resist and it didn't
work because they had the was it the
Excelsior app in New York yeah QR codes
American people were like nope yeah and
then you look we're we have big open
rural spaces so out here in West
Virginia there was basically nothing you
know you're trying whatever you want
you're trying to create some RFID real
life driver's license yeah what's that
that's supposed to come out that's been
out for a while there I have yeah I have
one is there some extreme states is
there some upgrade coming out this year
in the next six months or something I
don't know if it has RFID or what but I
think I think passport cards do though
right yeah I think so yeah so I've got
one of those when you apply for a sports
like your passport card it's a North
American ID and it's funny because I
tell people did you know that there's a
North American ID card and they're like
what you mean like an American like no
no like it's good for Canada the US and
Mexico it's an ID card that works in all
three places yes pass card I think yeah
passport you have your identification
card
um but after the G20 this year all the
world leaders came together and saying
that they need an international vaccine
passport system that they're going to be
implementing for the rest of the world
okay is are we clear now that covet came
and went and now there's like less
dangerous variants out there that people
are just living with I don't think much
has changed honestly
um it's just the propaganda just the
fear that's how we treat it and how
we're talking about it like like when it
comes to doctors and nurses that I talk
to they're like yeah not much not much
has changed except for the fear and
propaganda thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time